[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lavelle
the dropping of the fbi case against
michael flynn
reveals what so many of us have long
believed russiagate was a crude and
sloppy
invention to undermine the outcome of a
presidential election
irrespective of how you feel about the
current occupant of the white house
it was an attempted coup tellingly the
corporate liberal media
side with the conspirators
[Music]
to crosstalk obamacare i'm joined by
magus malik
abdul in washington he's a gop
strategist and
in new york we have lionel he is a legal
and media analyst all right gentlemen
crosstalk roles in effect that means you
can jump in anytime you want and i
always appreciate it well well well why
not let me go to you first uh i can't
count the number of times we've been on
this program where we've talked about
this
hoax called russiagate and now over the
last few days
well the hocus hoax has been revealed
for what it is it was as i said in my
introduction
it was a sloppy attempt to subvert
an election the 2016 election
the evidence is overwhelming but quite
curiously for three and a half years
we were told that there was enormous
evidence that there was a conspiracy
but as evidence comes out to point the
opposite the contrary
the mainstream media liberal media
pretends it's not even there oh and on
top of it
barr must be in cahoots with russia too
your thoughts my friend well in first of
all as a lawyer
what the prosecution is doing regarding
general flynn
really has nothing to do with the
absence or the presence of any kind of
russian involvement
what is the most important is that
whenever you have
something in which the dread fbi
is called to account remember peter
during the days of cointelpro
martin luther king the the the a
pervasive um
involvement of the fbi you would think
the prototypically
historic liberal media would be on the
side of justice
would say this is terrific finally a but
they're not
because if it is in any way connected
with trump
if it's part of this tds or trump
derangement syndrome they lose whatever
their
their philosophy used to be and they
just embrace anything to embarrass trump
no matter how specious the argument is
yeah media and
and power are fused together this time
around okay because there's a hip
yeah at the hip here well i mean let me
ask you i mean one of the things i found
very curious and i'm not
cherry picking here i think most people
would agree that
we had over the weekend obama coming out
from his man cave
on martha's vineyard and uh talking with
his cronies which of course it was
intentionally leaked and he's talking
about the flynn case now
over the last three and a half years how
often does he talk specifically about
politics and policy like that it's very
very curious to me oh
on top of that the trump administration
was warned about two people
as they started their tenure kim jong-un
and michael flynn
and now obama's talking about flynn it
seems to me in my humble opinion
this whole uh fake investigation because
there was no predicate of it
from michael flynn was invented in the
white house and run by the white house
and it's all coming back we're all
through time
piecing it all together connecting all
of the dots
and now it seems perfectly clear to me
the insurance policy was michael flynn
and the love birds
over at the fbi were keeping the white
house in the loop
it's all coming together what say you
yeah you you can you can add up the dots
and see where
this was going barack obama has done
something what other presidents in the
past typically
haven't done once they left office he's
always inserted himself
into the national discourse he's done
this once again we're talking about
michael flynn
and it's it's not just talking about it
would be different if barack obama were
talking about a political candidate
he's talking about a case that was
where we had an actual investigation
he's inserting himself into legal
matters
not surprising to me because i believe
that type of arrogance is something that
barack obama has had
um for quite some time but the the scale
of this and he's we we know there was
there was no russian collusion
to um throw the election in favor of
donald trump
we knew that from the beginning and so
three and a half so many years later
we're back at this with now we'll have
the revelation
that well hey well it seems as if that
insurance policy that you're talking
about
really was an insurance policy and what
i'm hoping from this
is that the um attorney general bar
really looks into it
someone needs to be held accountable we
can't just have people retire
or resign go to another agency someone
has to account for this because this
is not the way our system of justice
should be set up
well the way the media is behaving will
never get accountability because they're
constantly covering up
lionel you want to jump in go ahead you
know there's been an interesting
development
if you want to go into any kind of
hashtag
review which by the way sometimes is
telling for the first time people are
talking about
obama gate and it just so happens that
at this time that the president
reintroduced himself because normally as
you know historically
presidents well look at george w bush he
goes off to his dallas ranch and he
paints and that sort of thing
but for the for president obama to leave
his
martha's vineyard mans to reintroduce
himself at the same time
that his uh lieutenant susan rice
immediately at the moment before they
turned
the keys over to the white house said we
want to make sure
that we don't have any problems with the
trump administration
and russian collusion now what i'm
trying to say perhaps circuitously
is that many people are suggesting that
for the first time because people always
thought presidents were off limits that
they were
immune sometimes officially tacitly
expressly or whatever
but is it interesting that president
obama is coming forward
is it as a limited hangout to say i'm
gonna
come out now and explain to you my
position and then
should there be any kind of criminal
activity later on perhaps advance
he could say ah this is retaliation i'm
perhaps making this too labyrinthine
but it's not far-fetched i don't think
it's far-fetched at all it seems to me
you know the the simplest way of looking
at this is the most logical way you know
i
i i don't i you know i don't look at how
the
the media the way they spin it is it's
always deflection i mean i just want to
get to the strength of the straight of
it i mean
i said in my introduction irrespective
of how you feel about the occupant in
the white house right now
and and i really mean that okay because
what this is
is that you you have a fbi and a justice
department that is
radically out of control i mean and when
you look at the the 302s with
the interview with with michael flynn i
mean you know
get him fired get him to lie i mean i
mean that's not what the fbi is supposed
to do they're supposed to investigate
what they believe is a crime
they went there without a predicate and
that's why it was thrown out that
i'm not a lawyer you know and i'm not
even that smart of a guy okay but this
is very simple this is very simple stuff
here
if there was no predicate you can't do
that i mean even i
understand that go mike go ahead jump in
and because i think that
you know the media wants to skew
everything no it's just simple stuff
well it's been clear since donald trump
began running for president since he
first went down that elevator that the
media was not going to be favorable to
donald trump
and this is what barack obama is doing
now and what i'll say and i've said this
to a few people
barack obama is running for his third
re-election
that means his second re-election but
his third race
in order for br in order for joe biden
to have
any chance and i think he's going to
lose in order for him to have any chance
barack obama essentially has to cast
himself
as well here i am once again because joe
biden
can't do it alone expect barack obama to
come out with
other comments not just criticizing the
the
for instance the corona virus the
response to coronavirus barack obama is
going to be
out there campaigning against donald
trump so that he
by default joe biden can end up in the
white house that's what's happening
again
yeah but it isn't really interesting
that he's taking the michael flynn
case to reintroduce himself i mean from
my point of view that is a lose-lose you
know why because
biden was in the room okay he was in the
room
so okay i mean he's admitted it and
essentially so is obama so what did you
guys talk about and why were you talking
about the incoming national security
adviser
from the opposing camp and you know
sally yates she
doesn't understand what's going on how
did you get this transcript why are we
talking about him
i mean they're letting it out slowly
right here and this unmasking lionel
what i find really upsetting is that
so much of this unmasking happened in
the first few during the transition in
the first few months of the
administration
which is a felony particularly if it is
used for political purposes okay
and still we got crickets on that here
that's what i'm hoping that attorney
general barr will
finally tie up and explain to us
apparently there's a list of names that
have been
that have been uh put together of people
that were involved this unmasking
particularly in the case of michael
flynn go headline
well the new dni uh chief is going to be
looking into this but let me explain
especially to our uh international if
you will
audience you know we always talk about
russian yes in russia
and this heartless mindless soulless
well
let me tell you about our system the
department of justice has as its mandate
never to target prosecute if i want to
go after
you peter if somebody has to come to me
and say we have reason to believe
that something is going on and then we
investigate but i don't follow you
unless and until i find something let me
also bring you up to something
in my my friends who are have been
involved in the
representation of let's say certain
organized uh
crime fellows when they got to be a
little old
there was an expression in the
courthouse called the sicilian flu
which all of a sudden these people
became very very infirm and they needed
doctors and wheelchairs and they
couldn't testify
the grand jury you know people say no
he's too now
isn't it funny that the main person who
was running for office
normally would be disqualified dare i
say as being a
doterra dotard but yet can use
his laps of memory almost as a defense
isn't it interesting when he says i
don't really remember this
i'm not sure was i there and people are
saying we've become
acclimated to the fact i'm sorry to say
and this is not meant as a
a slam against those people who are
truly mentally confirmed
but this is a guy who basically says i
don't even know where he talks about
corn pop and he's blond hair and i mean
he talks about he waxes logo away like
about stuff we don't understand
so we have this is almost a bad
version of veep this is the weirdest
situation comedy
but it's serious in the meantime i will
just say this i don't know if the
american people truly understands the
the gravity
and the and the the evil nature of what
this represents because i think we're
just
coping crazy right now i mean i know i
mean it's no wonder it's no wonder they
don't understand the gravity of it if
you're not
told about it if you if there's no
reporting on it
how can you be worried okay i mean this
is their
this is their utopia have your head in
the sand okay
you know and this is what's really
terrifying that you know again i want to
stay away from you know
uh being far against trump that's not
what this program is about here but if
this
isn't addressed and if there isn't a
remedy
it's going to happen again all right and
somebody needs to be held responsible to
make sure
that you know don't ever do it because
the consequences are great
last 30 seconds go ahead before we go
this is something that we're going to
continue experience under
any republican administration so it
really doesn't matter that it's donald
trump the media is not favorable to
republicans
at all and this is an extension of that
so i expect us to see more of these type
of stories whether it's media covering
up
suggesting that donald trump said that
this was a hoax or not
this is what the media is going to
continue to do under any
republican press and that and that
creates a lane for
all three of us we're going to go to a
short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on
obamacare
stay with our team
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter labelle
remind you we're discussing obamacare
[Music]
okay let's go back to lionel here you
know lionel one of the other things the
the other
dots that you know seem to be connecting
here we have adam schiff's
um uh um witness um um
transcripts here and i i really don't
want to waste a lot of time on it
because
it's always the same answer but if you
go from one luminary to the next so
let's let me set it up here so
you know they're on cnn and msnbc and
you know
it's damaging it's overwhelming it's
this
it's that it's treason but then under
oath
they all said well i didn't see anything
i don't know anything
i mean this is what's really amazing is
that you
have these people almost uniformly have
a public voice
damning the president inserting
themselves into a a political
investigative process because those were
during the mueller days here but when it
when push comes the show
when they put their hand on the bible
and they take an oath
they say something very different almost
no one in the mainstream
wants to talk about that disparity and
on top of it i want to finish the
program as we go further in
maybe youtube should start deleting all
of those videos because it's fake news
go ahead lionel well a couple of things
you know i wish that we could be
instrument rated in terms of media
and analysis for example an
instrument-rated pilot is somebody who
says i don't need to even see where i'm
going i can look down and say
if given this situation plus this we go
in this particular course
if you ever were to ask somebody in the
mainstream media today the fake news
media to borrow a term
what do you think about a president who
had
someone a successor come in and tell
that president they would say
who's the president it doesn't matter
hypothetically assuming argumento they
couldn't answer the question
okay it was obama oh well okay well that
excuse me i lied it was trump if you
cannot see
the glaring intellectual
disingenuous pap this bunkum
and i'm trying to contain myself but
here's my problem though peter
i think people have become so habituated
so used to so conditioned to these lies
they don't recognize it anymore they
don't react to it it's like okay another
story another lie
and if somebody said i love this and he
said there's no such thing there's no
rule where you can't lie on tv
which is true but i actually heard
somebody say well that was in court
but you can lie on msdnc or mslsd or
whatever you want to do and i thought to
myself
do we have to have a a statute
that that prescribes you know a perjury
can we just tell the truth honestly no
that's where we've gone you know melanie
it's very interesting to me
is that you hear this constant mantra
you know about
norms and the rule of law well
what norm is it when you're trying to
commit a coup against a duly elected
president what is
normal about that what norms are they
referring to
and then the rule of law well i suppose
you know barack obama he
he did get a degree in constitutional
law i'm i'm not mistaken
i mean if he didn't understand if he
doesn't understand what
his administration and maybe he
personally did
to general flynn i think then he has to
turn in his diploma
okay because the way things are going
this is going to be the most disgraceful
presidency of all
presidency when you go after the man
the person that was elected behind you
that is so
that is unconscionable you know and i
try to keep my
faith okay but i mean this is
unconscionable behavior
and the media's covering up is equally
unconscionable go ahead
absolutely and that's why i said this
happens under any in under
really any republican administration and
in fact if we
if we really go back and look at how
bill clinton behaved when george bush is
in office
he may have every now and again inserted
himself with the criticism but it was
rare that you saw bill clinton coming
out publicly
interjecting himself into a national
discussion the same thing happened once
barack obama got into office you didn't
see george w bush
coming into you know inserting himself
into the national discourse
this is happening because we have a
media apparatus that refuses to hold
itself accountable the things that the
media the things that the democrats
the things that they used to agree with
for instance whether it's something like
border walls they no longer agree with
those things whether you should
respect the office even if you don't
respect the person
respect the office because that's what
we heard all eight years of barack obama
that was thrown out of the window as
soon as donald trump went down those
stairs
and won the election so this hypocrisy
knows no bounds
when it comes to the media so it really
is up to me it's up to you it's up to
lionel it's up to all of us to really do
what we can
to counter the media narrative because
it's such a huge
huge huge gap in how they treat
republicans versus
democrats and i think that's the issue
not necessarily trump
it is republican versus democrat liberal
versus conservative
well i think it's how liberals treat the
truth because truth is only necessary
or good or useful
in pursuit of their power okay that i
mean look at the metoo movement we went
from believe
all women to believe joe what happened
there
what happened there okay i mean i
and my position on that has always been
the same you have to listen to anyone
that makes a complaint of that magnitude
it doesn't matter who the person is it
doesn't matter who the
what station they have in life and it
doesn't matter who it's directed against
okay
my position is very simple okay theirs
is very convoluted depending on the
circumstances
you know lionel chapter over at nbc he
did a i oh yeah i mean you think you
think you see the lowest of lows
okay and then what they did this
attacking of attorney general barr
i mean that that's what stalin's
apparatchiki
did the splicing and the cutting and the
twisting
i've been using apparatchik though not
as
pronounced as artfully as you but
imagine if i took what you
said there is a com you have a quote
i then take that quote i
splice it remove the answer and then go
on tv and say
why didn't he say this now in law
in our first amendment we have new york
times against sullivan which deals with
things like
libel slander defamation
we don't have anything called
non-seasons where you don't do your job
it's not
negligence it's the deliberate and
intentional
refusal to do a job and there is no
cause of action for it there's no
statute
you can't hold people accountable so if
i were to have give you an incomplete
police report
an incomplete doctor's report radiology
report
anything where you're reading this and i
said i didn't lie
i just didn't give you the complete
picture the american public
should be absolutely enraged and one one
more thing
you and i keep using phrases from our
past
left right liberal conservative this has
nothing to do with liberals
this is this is a a dark force that i
can't even understand
what their goal is it is get trump
that's it not even get conservatives or
reagan or any it's
you know i think that's that's such a
fascinating point and we've talked about
this on number of occasions in different
venues about the poverty of our
political language
i agree with you 100 and we need to
start getting away from it the thing is
is i don't know what
what the next paradigm is and we grapple
with that here right
it's really about i think in in its in
broader sense it's about the
preservation of their privileges
okay that's what it's all about i mean
look at you know nancy pelosi's
this insane uh um uh stimulus package
you know
has nothing to do with the with the
pandemic it's a way to get all their
goodies in
you know things that we should have a
debate about
and have elections about that's how the
process no
no this is done behind closed doors they
bring up all this funny money for all
their funny
weird projects that no one asked me
about
because i would say no i don't want to
do that i want to waste money on that i
want to help
working families i want to help small
businesses
that's what we should be doing but no
this is exactly what the media does it
just
echo chambers all the time because the
media they want the preservation of
their
privilege and their access and of course
their six-figure jobs
and their pampered lifestyle because
reporting the news it's not reporting
this it's celebrity it's a form of
celebrity
has nothing to do with informing people
because you know what both of you in my
audience
if you did inform people they'd pull out
a pitchfork
that's what would happen oh yeah that's
what they would do
and they will do it because nobody
believes these fools anymore okay can
you get off the fence
i'm scaring my dogs
no let me go back to you i mean
for me i guess my i don't expect much
from politicians ever
and i don't care what stripe they are
but in my profession
i do i have to call people out okay and
i will
never stop doing that because i have to
look at myself in the mirror every day
and just say this calls balls and
strikes okay
they're not even playing the game
they're doing something else completely
in a different dimension
i think this is the real problem in
these people these conspirators because
that's exactly what they are
they get the cover of the media and they
think they're going to get away with it
and you know what they just might go
ahead
well they have been getting away with it
if we look at the
the what the media does how they
influence polls
whether it's a situation where they make
a they make a big stink about donald
trump saying to a reporter
who happens to be asian-american go ask
china
something that he's talked about he's
blamed china since
i think probably early february so it
doesn't matter that he said this many
different times
before even the reporter herself and
this is what this is what the media does
they want they want to become trending
stories
and so you saw with that reporter on
that day she asked
the president well why are you saying
that to me well
because he said it to everyone else but
what she wanted to do was put out there
and the media
immediately followed up with donald
trump as
asian-american reporter to go ask china
this is what the media does no you know
what it is you know what it is has
nothing to do with the woman's
ethnicity at all you know you know what
it has everything to do with this
she's a snowflake okay that's the group
she's in
a snowflake and you know being a
snowflake is colorblind
because there's snowflakes everywhere
all right and you know
the tall thing about trump being a
racist it's never got any traction with
me
if any person in in modern life of the
last 40 years
has dealt with every single racial group
it's been donald trump he's been in
he's been in entertainment he's been in
business i mean
you don't get far be having a closed
mind and then
you know i have my criticisms of the
president and they can be they're
numerous
numerous okay but that one doesn't go
anywhere because
i'm sorry i don't believe in being
triggered okay we got bigger problems to
worry about lionel finish it up 25
seconds
you know i'm here i got to take
something in new york and i'm pointing
to where the
the comfort was this was the the ship
which left in the middle of the night
and we don't know why
down the street is a javits center where
they had 3 000 beds
that were going to handle the death the
death of these people
at hospitals a couple of blocks away we
had refrigerated
uh trailers to handle the the cords of
wood of body stock
do you know that when none of this
happened not one
person from the mainstream media said
hey what about that hey fauci
hey cbc where they don't because you
know what
that doesn't help the agenda of hurting
president trump that's right that's
right okay because it doesn't get the
story out they want just protect their
privilege that's all the time we have
gentlemen many thanks to my guests in
in new york and in washington and thanks
to our viewers who are watching us here
at rt see you next time remember
crosstalk news